[Music]  stephen what are you sure you want to  know  we deliver justice  i like the sound of that  i'm really chased about showing you  these new skill sets i have  a suit this is menthol  power  am i like some sort of secret agent  it's a little more complicated than that  marvel studios moon night only on disney  plus  stephen there he is hello man in the  mirror i know you're scared a bit yeah i  know you're confused you weren't  supposed to see any of this  what are you sure you want to know  [Applause]  mark you look different  i can't tell the difference  between my waking lives  [Music]  and dreams  am i like some sort of secret agent  it's a little more complicated than that  we protect the vulnerable  and deliver justice  this is the best worst day of my life  marvel studios moon night only on disney  plus  [Music]